on va continuer à parler sport Faustine
cette fois-ci basket et les joueurs de
l'AD Blois ont rencontré des collégiens
hier et on y était et ce n'est pas la
première fois qu'il en rencontrre
l'équipe a l'habitude de se rendre dans
des établissements scolaires deux fois
par an en contrepartie d'une aide
financière du département l'objectif
expliquer leur sport le basket et faire
par parler de leurs conditions de vie en
tant que joueur professionnel un moment
de détente à pour partager leur passion
avec les plus jeunes hélè chapelet a
suivi la rencontre ils sont géants ils
sont
gentils assez grands et ils sont
forts pratiquer le basket avec des
joueurs professionnels ce n'est pas
donné à tout le monde une centaine
d'élèves du collège Lano à vandô ont eu
la chance de passer leur lundi
après-midi avec 10 joueurs de la DA
Blois divers ateliers étaient organisés
pour se retrouver en petit groupe ici
par exemple les filles sont opposé aux
garçons et à chaque panier marqué la
zone de lancé change on appelle ça un
tour du monde et à ce moment-là c'est
l'équipe des garçons qui domine les
garçons vous avez le droit de donner une
sanction aux
filles 10 pompes sur les genoux 10
pompes sur les genoux c'est parti sur
les genou c'est bien ça nous permet de
de sortir du quotidien un peu c'est
sympa c'est des moments d'échange donc
ils sont contents de nous voir moi nous
on est content de les voir aussi et
c'est
[Musique]
sympa vas-y double double double 2 3 4 5
c'est la passe à 10 et il faut utiliser
tout l'espace du terrain et on essaie de
de leur inculquer un petit peu le cet
esprit d'espace et d'utiliser vraiment
tout l'espace du terrain et de bouger et
de se démarquer on nous apprend à faire
les drible et
tout et ils nous apprennent leur
nutrition comment ils vivent ouais parce
que c'est un sport de haut niveau il
doiv s'entraîner tous les jours on a
appris à tirer avec deux mains et plein
d'autres choses on apprend à travailler
en
groupe cette opération a lieu deux fois
par an dans deux établissements scolaire
du Loir etcher une contrepartie demandée
par le Conseil départemental en échange
de son soutien financier pour le club de
basket l'occasion surtout pour ces
jeunes générations de mieux appréhender
les particularités de ce sport et de
faire connaissance avec ceux qui
évoluent parmi l'élite du basket
[Applaudissements]
français